les stars du jour c'était eux le
personnel du centre hospitalier
intercommunal de poissy saint germain en
laye des soignants accueilli sous les
applaudissements pour ce nouveau match
du variétés club de france
retrouvailles avec les administrés
retrouvailles avec les copains du s'agit
point si j'ai une licence avec lui
depuis 25 ans maintenant c'est
formidable ce qu'ils ont fait pendant ce
que vides et puis retrouvailles avec
avec toutes les stars du variétés ya
aucun enjeu sportif
le seul enjeu qui y est c'est le plaisir
surpris mais c'est le plaisir du coeur
une trentaine d'anciens footballeurs
professionnels a répondu à l'invitation
de jacques vendroux le manager du
variétés parmi eux plusieurs membres de
l'équipe étoilée de 1998 c'est un sujet
qui nous tient à coeur et voilà la
grande famille du football s'est réuni
et évidemment le personnel hospitalier
aussi et on se doit de faire cet effort
là pour ceux qui nous en garantie des
vies qui ont sauvé des vies et qui
continue à essayer de sauver des vies
c'est un plaisir parce que bon ils ont
été soumis à rude à rude épreuve
durant sept heures cette crise sanitaire
et c'est aussi pour eux qu'un jour là on
joue pas pour nous on joue pour les
autres donc c'est vraiment ça l'idée
face à de grands noms on en vient même à
faire la fine bouche quand on tousse
cover j'aurais bien oui ça c'est arsène
wenger voit tout simplement moi c'est le
coach que j'ai toujours aimé étant jeune
kg et arsenal pour la petite histoire
c'est la variété qui remporte le match
score final 4 buts à 1
[Applaudissements]